all right let's jump into this first
story from timcast.com Tulsi gabbard
quits Democratic party citing wokeness
and anti-white racism calls the party
existential threat to America and urges
other party members to join her that's
just the story she gave a speech saying
nonetheless I can no longer remain in
today's Democratic party it's now under
the complete control of an elitist cabal
of War mongers driven by cowardly
wokeness who divide Us by racializing
every issue in stoking anti-white racism
who actively worked to undermine our
god-given freedoms and shrined in our
Constitution and who are hostile to
people of faith and spirituality who
demonize the police who who protect
criminals at the expense of the law
well that's good news as far as I'm
concerned but I do think she should have
come out and stated this a long time ago
absolutely right I mean finally welcome
to the nightmare that the overwhelming
majority of us have been living for you
know for quite some time